that was really scared because I had
never been shot at before that was Megan
speaking with CBS mornings back in April
yesterday she took the stand as a
witness during the second day of the
assault trial against Canadian rapertory
Lanes who was accused of shooting her in
the foot in July 2020.
trial Megan described her account of the
night saying the alleged assault was a
result of an argument she had with Tory
Lanez and Kelsey Harris her former best
friend when Los Angeles County Deputy
district attorney Kathy ta asked Megan
if she was having a hard time opening up
the rapper reportedly replied I'm having
a really difficult time sitting up here
telling my story and having to sit
across from people who have made up lies
about me and having to sit across from
Tori adding quote I tried to be strong I
don't like to look weak I don't want to
give them the power that they've taken
from me for the last three years Megan
explains during her four hours on the
stand that the argument began after they
left Kylie Jenner's house and claims
that Tory Lanez was upset that she made
them leave the party she says they began
arguing over their musical careers and
when she asked to get out of the car
Tory Lanez allegedly opened fire on her
wounding her feet Megan began to get
emotional as she told the court about
the impact the shooting has had on her
life saying quote I don't feel like I
want to be on this Earth I wish he would
have just shot and killed me if I knew I
would have to go through this torture
Tory Lanez attorney claims he is
innocent a lot of people don't want to
be a part of this nobody wants to get
involved he has pleaded not guilty to
three felony charges and if convicted he
could face up to 22 years in prison